isabelle morini-bosc donc en père fouras
enora malagré dans la boule et doha ça
va vous avez froid on va vous faire
tourner ce que vous êtes angoissé
oui très alors vous allez devoir
répondre à des énigmes à chaque fois
vous on donnera 100 200 puis 300 euros
pour une association
d'accord il aura est ce que vous êtes
prête on a déjà 300 euros au compteur
attention écoutez bien les énigmes
isabelle vous êtes prête
oui la mer four est prête à l'aise
c'est la meilleure c'est la meilleure
alors c'est bon vous êtes prête bret et
virginie vous pourrez danser un peu pour
nous après pourquoi ce que vous êtes
excitante quand vous danser on parle du
cisi delaune celle ci qui se les gèle et
puis vous voulez que je danse d'accord
mais j'adorerais même bolivien pour moi
ça reste de faire retomber mais c'est
vrai ils ont commencé ça doit vous avez
perdu votre slip
alors cette période tu parles tu veux
aller s'est produit les années passent
mais je voyage souvent les voitures et
passants je me soulage deux mois gilles
verdez au t1 son surnom gillet voilà les
genres gagner le quoi le quoi
ils attendaient un taux d eau boueuse
auto pas allez-y deuxième énigme bien
minime
on peut le porter hiver comme été tout
quartier veulent savoir
je change de sens si l'on me prononce en
anglais
jean marie bigard mamie sur ses affiches
je soutiens la bourse va soyez points à
riesch mais des testicules
non ça va je m'étonne que sur les
testicules aussi pourquoi la trêve et le
cil bravo rôle à jouer à temps la 3d
trois mois vous écouter et des grappes
on paie toi je peux pas parler dire
ouais le charme a dans sa ligne de mire
grâce à mes pas que je porte bonheur
c'est la moutarde jeu cuisant la paix
mineurs quoi la moutarde quoi je pense
je pars dans ma vie des gens peu plus à
chaque sens ma danse à lui il y en a qui
sont chauds il y en a qui sont pas
chauds de quads etc et des des déserts
on fait quoi
d'un animal une biche en serre dont on y
arrivera là-bas on voit très bien
braderie des ouvriers pas le faire ça je
la vois j'ai déjà envie de rendre non
c'est vrai ah non mais moi c'est
terrible c'est bravo à doha
alors pour ceux qui loin de ça chez lui
elle est en dessous
voilà donc elle est là voilà et ont joué
pour les anges de la rue voilà qui
viennent en aide à des sg à des sdf et
donc on leur fera un chèque de 1000
euros pour leur accession à la fin de
l'émission d'arthur music et ce cas là
ça va il y aura sans doute trouvé cette
image de vous voulez pas savoir comment
jouer moi mais vous vous avez à la fée
mais non c'est à vous d'en fois à ton
quartier de quoi maintenant
oh